well talk about perfect timing today
governor andrew cuomo announced that new
york's masked mandate it will be lifted
on wednesday for the fully vaccinated
now you're thinking okay he's following
the cdc he's a little late just like he
was with
approving the vaccine right great news
but just a little late was he following
science
or was it a distraction late today
cuomo's taxes
were also released revealing that he
raked in five million dollars from the
book he wrote
on the coveted crisis joining me now to
react new york post columnist
and fox news contributor miranda divine
miranda thank you for being here
with me so here is the hero the
counterpoint to president trump the
media and the left's hero
of the coronavirus pandemic and now we
know from his
taxes he profited nicely from that image
well dean it's incredibly obscene
that he's made so much money out of this
he was
writing a book while people were dying
how callous do you have to be
especially when you are responsible it
is your fault
that 15 000 elderly people died of
covert in nursing homes because you
issued
the order that infected people should be
sent from hospitals into those nursing
homes which went against
all the known science we knew that in
florida that governor desantis
did the opposite he moved to look after
the nursing homes look after the elderly
protect them
because they are the ones who are most
at risk from covert
and you had andrew cuomo just puffing
himself up on television every day
being fated by the great and the good
given and emmy
treated as if he was some sort of a hero
and as you said
he was the antithesis supposedly
of donald trump who actually was doing
things that were saving lives
like on january 31st stopping flights
from china like
doing the big 12 billion dollar bet on
the vaccines
so you have on the one hand a president
who is vilified by the media
for doing things that saved lives while
andrew cuomo
was doing things that were actively
demonstrably
killing people and now he's made five
million dollars
and that works out that's blood money a
hundred
dollars per dead new yorker i hope he
enjoys it wow that's a way to put it and
that's a serious
fine point to put on that i began your
answer smiling miranda because one of
the
byproducts of this coronavirus pandemic
has been that people work remotely
you and i haven't had the chance to meet
so i will forgive you but i have to tell
you
i'm not sadly dean kane sorry i'm
willing
but the problem is if i'm going to be
mixed up with anyone i'm happy for it to
be superman
so you are forgiven for that miranda
thank you very much
on the way out i want to ask you about
new jersey governor phil murphy i just
talked about vaccine mandates and
vaccine passports coming to us very soon
it appears in new jersey that could be
not far away as phil murphy seems to
have given the thumbs up
to private businesses requiring vaccine
passports what are your thoughts
well phil murphy is you know slightly
worse than andrew cuomo he has the most
per capita deaths from covert in the
country
and andrew cuomo has the most i i
i think phil murphy has been a shocking
governor
and i feel sorry for the people of new
jersey in my view
anything he says is wrong all right
miranda devine
i would be funny and call you tammy
bruce but that jet jokes already run its
course
all right thank you miranda thank you so
much all right thanks will
dean you got one up on me you'll always
be here i'm chasing you dean kane
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else